ciao a tutti il maggior rotazioni the
street
oggi andiamo a creare se me la mia me
molti anni moggi e musi come la volete
chiamare in più vi posso anche vedere
come creare la vostra me molti i punti
che moggi nel caso aveste bisogno di
istruzioni in realtà io non lo so perché
non l'ho ancora fatto ma lo scopriremo
assieme
comunque vada creare teme l'avremo oggi
puoi fare che stare nei commenti se il
secondo voi mi somiglia davvero o no
siete pronti ok allora innanzitutto
bisogna andare su imessage e cliccare su
a minuti poi cliccando sulla pagina
della scimmietta vedrete ciao in più un
messaggio con l'attuale musica preferita
o crea una mia vc personalizzata
continua ok che clicchiamo su più è
compatto allora dobbiamo selezionare la
carnagione la mia è molto chiara quindi
seleziono questa sta già parlando ma te
faccio le mie espressioni impressione
anita appena alta dello schermo phone
comunque posso anche aumentare a
diminuire
no questo è troppo bianca forse questa
sera poi 20 g no non ho lentissimi
quindi niente taglio di capelli
vediamo se c'è un taglio simile al mio
forse questo punto con corti che pensate
mi fa ridere che già sto parlando sono
decisamente troppo corti ma non so se ci
siano più lunghi bello che stesse bene
questo taglio forse per sapere che si
somigliano di più
scrivete nei commenti
secondo voi quali hanno queste sono più
corti e di un commissario per questo è
conclusa la mia professoressa di
italiano
poi ci sono anche vari pettinature 100
premi tutti i tipi che per maschietti
dopo facciamo quella diventata magari
come vista male evitare quindi non lo
distribuiamo in questi giorni allora tra
queste non si vuole scegliere il pezzo
forse questa no sono grossi o questi g
no perché sono tutti i collari calcetto
questi questi non sokol serie ciao
per minuto tutto quali cappelli stesso
milioni temi questi queste sono spesso
questi su questi questa carica al centro
quelli che somigliano di più
ok ok quindi abbiamo senza i capelli e
il colore un po più sicuro non troppo
dire che così ci siamo poi forma della
testa colpito un po lungo quindi direi
che questa va bene direi che ne pensate
occhi
secondo voi quali sono i propri atti per
me
possono troppo grandi che carina ok
proviamo con questi poi si sa se
mettiamo è queste feste sopracciglia ma
il colore degli occhi ad avere un basso
ed è un po allora in realtà non sono
solo un po chi ma un po verdolini forse
così ci siamo
no no ok questi direi che vanno bene
sopracciglia non lo so sono abbastanza
sottili forse queste queste sono
abbastanza semplici naso e labbra sono
tremati ma come poi labbra
[Musica]
che dite mi metto il rossetto no il
rossetto che adesso il viola carina dire
questo si assomigliano abbastanza ore e
che queste orecchini
no in realtà non riporto barba oddio mi
sarebbe molto bene vuol dire il pizzetto
interessante come mista il barbone ok no
niente barba cui si toglie oddio come
vittoriano stricchi nuovo non si toglie
un addio che si toglie anno è problemi
con stazionare questo ok occhialino
splendido copricapi un uso così mai
quindi direi che ci stiamo buon fine
eccola qua per te la mia negozi o bene
creata cosa ne pensate
secondo voi da 1 a 10 quanto mi somiglia
non c'era tantissima personalizzazione
di sambro con questa personalizzazione
pack che o meno di lei è un po mi
somiglia pieni
mi somiglia no no
secondo se devo cambiare qualcosa ma
poco troppo troppo di nastri accennerà
non sono tre veramente insomma tre no
perchè dici questo lo zucchetto questo
dovrei cambiare qualcosa secondo te
[Musica]
molto ben voi proverete a letto vuoto
focarina ok ora proviamo a credere che
[Musica]
non fa ti creo io non ti preoccupare
vediamo sempre perché sentito tutto
all'improvviso di qua forse prende anche
lasciati faccia con le mie espressioni e
inespressiva con la traccia più
possibile
che strano così da cambiate gruppi
espressioni colata falsa questo più
allegra allora cliccare il malato solo
un rapprentare per lui è come se
stessimo rendono i ragazzi come contro
malattie
quando divenne raffreddore o appendere
alla fine del pezzo
mamma mia allora facciamo l'animo zitti
valcanale dell'area quando mamma mia che
passo la vita del tuo che io e bianchi
so che tu io ok chi somiglia finale
medicina un taglio di capelli cercato
soprattutto nota non è più quella
riforma ci mette una pezza
non proprio
no ormai suppone così un po più corto si
vorrebbe sul fondo vediamo i ciclo
boccia ballo da allora forse questo qua
la casa è il cuore di questi tour e
qualche ti somiglia di più
poi penso puoi cambiare c'è stata tanta
e si chiama sì forse che quell'altro si
direbbe da bella tonda
occhi
colini non troppo piccoli questi dalla
cella se questi questi di ciglia che
ciglio cui queste sopracciglia vicina
così grosso modo per questo era un
gruppo definite hanno ragione non quello
che aspetta perché abbiamo sbagliato i
capelli non c'è neanche se chiari
infatti ci sono più scuri anche gli
occhi sono più sicuri ok sopraccigli
allora quel terzo di piazza grosso naso
e labbra su piccoli poi la piccolina si
nota che bastos che la pratica orecchie
giganti delle grosse gli enormi
orecchini quelli finiti voi ma io mi
piace dormire
poi parla la benedizione ai no no non ho
detto l'assessore si trovano anche
questo è troppo
[Musica]
che batte strane 20 piazze per bastone
vediamo qual è la più corta che
frequenta questa legge ok b
in realtà vita report agli occhiali
perché una tacchetta però nel non divide
non li metteva in questi che in finale
piccolino inquadra express bellissimo
l'italiano e andiamo solo ma giungerà
intorno cappelletti no
ok abbiamo finito vediamo la cia credo
mi alzassi perché espressione
secondo voi quanto somiglia avvitare da
1 a 10 questa memoria teheran ei
commenti e scrivere sul secondo queste
somiglia di più vitale al somme voce o
io alla mia memoria
vediamo ora la problemi col in
espressioni finalmente sorride queste
voci
sono molti i raffreddori e niente
cattivo ma perché si blocca detto non
meri colosso di gelo che si intitolava
che chi è allora ragazzo fa sapere se si
assomigliano nel primo oggi a noi ora
avete anche visto come voi avete fatto
la vostra musi manda temperature su
instagram aubrey pubblicatela state
l'asta cantastorie così le vedo fatemi
sapere cosa ne pensate delle voci e se
ci somigliano e allora mi lasciavo bar
quattro cattedre su cui cliccare per
vedere i prossimi video le nostre sale
dossier meno sfide divertenti che su
quella che preferite e buona visione da
me e dalla bmw ci sarà
[Musica]
no